(Middle Eastern music)
- Oh dear.
- Why does this happen to me?
- The words that come to
mind with belly dancing:
sensual,
sexy.
Belly dancing is just like a sexy dance.
- Something I wanna tap into is being able
to be in charge of my
body and really feel sexy.
- Belly dancers have a very wavy belly.
- My body just doesn't move like that.
I've got beautiful long dancers legs.
But my belly, I put a
lot of Chipotle into it
so it just hangs out.
- I don't feel like I'm going to be sexy.
I will try.
- Hopefully I'm good at distracting people
with some pouty lips and
some smoldering eyes.
(gong)
- Let's start off by
warming up those hips.
You know what we need for this?
Crucial piece of costuming
and that is your coin belt.
- The coin belt was incredible.
I, I didn't know this was going to come
with such elaborate costuming.
- It was literally like
the icing on the cake
because when you're
shaking, you really feel it
and you just come alive.
- (mumbles)
(jingling)
Shimmy.
- When we found out that
having a belly is celebrated
in belly dancing, I was happy because
I've got some goodies down there.
- Egyptian walk, I
don't know what that is.
- A lot of that.
- [Emma] Practice walking
around in a circle with this.
- I felt like a rooster.
- [Emma] Let's have a little shimmy.
- I was born to shimmy.
Shimmying is just sorta
like hey, look at me.
Look at this guy.
- Step.
- I've got fairly big feet.
My rhythm is terrible.
- Yeah, yeah, we got, yeah, nailed it.
- I'm going forward and then
I'm sucking in, in, in, in.
- [Shane] I had, like, a big
bowl of pasta right before.
- [Robin] It was just like a
big belly that wouldn't move.
I didn't really feel sexy.
- I was rolling my body the wrong way.
Belly dancing is hard.
- [Robin] I didn't know it
was so much like (slurps).
- It's not often that you get
to dance with a live band.
I felt like a little majestic prince boy.
The way that they played
their little drums for us,
it was truly one of the
great experiences of my life.
And I've been to Santa's Village.
- Belly dance is
traditionally performed at
celebratory events like weddings.
A lot of it is really
about your interaction with
the audience and being very
playful with the audience.
- There's a lot of work in
the face and the expressions
because when you're
moving toward the audience
you're sorta like uh-oh,
watch out, here I come.
- [Emma] Attitude.
- And then suddenly when they're like yes,
come here, oh no, no, no.
- Rolling back.
You can be a little bit
flirty and like smile
at the audience as you're moving back.
- Uh-oh, I'm sleepy,
oh, bye, see you later.
Got to take a little nap.
We all got that down.
- [Robin] It's a fine line between creepy
and sexy and that line is us.
- The veil added the level of mystery.
- Flying.
I like capes, I felt like a superhero.
- [Emma] So graceful, do you guys think
you can turn as you do that?
- [Carl] Oh, for sure.
- I did get trapped in the
veil but you know what?
Happy to get lost in that,
it's my own little world in there.
- [Emma] And you're going side to side.
- [Shane] When you go side
to side are you just moving
your whole head because I was...
- [Emma] No. (laughs)
- Oh, okay, I've been...
Those other two, they enjoyed the veil.
I make it a part of me.
- [Emma] You're very mysterious.
- Oh, hee hee hee.
You see me, you can't touch me.
- My eyes can get very smoldery.
I love that veil.
- The motion is back, back, back.
(laughs)
Okay, bring your hands up.
- We're very good at performing when Emma
was dancing with us.
And then she cut us loose and things...
- [Carl] It was a lot.
A lot of choreography
that I wasn't expecting.
I would be lying if I
said I wasn't overwhelmed.
- [Shane] With the three of us,
the failure just compounded.
Because I'd be looking at Robin,
he was probably looking at me,
I was probably looking at Carl,
and all of us had no
idea what we were doing.
- You have time to practice.
- What?
- Before you perform it.
(record scratch)
- No.
- Wait, what?
- On Friday?
I should have known.
She wouldn't let us just do it
and then be like well, yeah,
it was fun, see you later.
- One little surprise
that I have up my sleeve
is that I've ordered
them their own costumes.
- Oh my god, I love that costume.
- [Shane] Those tiny silky little vests.
Giant poofy pants.
Just adds to the immersion.
Makes me feel like the real deal.
- [Robin] When I put on that outfit
I felt a little bit like Aladdin.
I like Aladdin.
- [Shane] We're gonna look incredible.
- We are Destiny's Belly.
- Emma has also told
us that it is customary
for audiences to boost
the morale of the dancers
with a very elegant (zaghareet sounds).
(zaghareet sounds)
- (zaghareet sounds)
- Which I hope our audience
instinctually knows to do.
(gong)
- I was very nervous going on.
(Middle Eastern music)
(audience cheers)
- I tried to keep eye contact
and just really, really seduce the crowd.
- I basically just followed Shane and Carl
and they nailed it.
- [Shane] It was really interesting
to learn about the dance.
There's something very
distinctive about it
and you do feel like you're embracing
another culture in a way
that you don't usually.
- [Robin] I had a good time,
we had a good laugh too.
We laughed a lot.
- Man, someone sign these guys.
Get them on tour.
- Tens across the board.
- When's the next one, I'm in it.
- I don't, maybe I was
swept up in the moment
but I don't recall hearing
any (zaghareet sounds).
You forgot?
That's all I was waiting for.